we're at a critical moment our leaders
some of our great institutions are
failing us why in some cases is because
they're bad or unethical but often
they've taken us to the wrong objectives
and this is unacceptable this has to
stop
how are we going to correct these wrongs
how are we going to choose the right
course it's not going to be easy for
years I've worked with talented teams
and they've chosen the right objectives
and the wrong objectives many of succeed
others of them have failed and today I'm
going to share with you what really
makes a difference
that's what's crucial how and why they
said meaningful and audacious goals the
right goals for the right reasons let's
go back to 1975 yep this is me I got a
lot to learn I'm a computer engineer I
got long hair but I'm working under Andy
Grove who's been called the greatest
manager of his or any other era Andy was
a superb leader and also a teacher and
he said to me John it almost doesn't
matter what you know execution is what
matters the most and so Andy invented a
system called objectives and key results
kind of rolls off the tongue doesn't it
and it's all about excellent execution
so here's a classic video from the 1970s
of Professor Andy Grove to key phrases
of the management by objective systems
are at your GEB thieves and Akina
dissolve and they match the two purposes
the objective is the direction the key
result has to be measure but at the end
you can look and without any arguments
did I do that did I not do it yes no
simple and that's Andy yes no simple
objectives and key results
or okay ours are a simple goal-setting
system and they work for organizations
they work for teams they even work for
individuals the objectives are what you
want to have accomplished the key
results are how I'm going to get that
done objectives key results what and how
but here's the truth
many of us are setting goals wrong and
most of us are not setting goals at all
a lot of organizations set objectives
and meet them they ship their sales they
introduce their new products they make
their numbers but they lack a sense of
purpose to inspire their teams so how do
you set these goals the right way first
you must answer the question why why
because truly transformational teams
combined their ambitions to their
passion into their purpose and they
develop a clear and compelling sense of
why I want to tell you a story I work
with a remarkable entrepreneur her name
is Jeanie Kim she runs a company called
nuna nuna is a health care data company
and when nuna was founded they used data
to serve the health needs of lots of
workers at large companies and then two
years into the company's life the
federal government issued a proposal to
build the first-ever cloud database for
Medicaid now you'll remember that
Medicaid is that program that serves 70
million Americans our poor our children
and people with disabilities noona at
the time was just 15 people and this
database had to be built in one year and
they had a whole set of commitments that
they had to honor and frankly they
weren't going to make very much money on
the project this was a bet year company
moment and Jeanie seized it she jumped
at the opportunity she did not flinch
why well it's a personal line Jeannie's
younger brother Dee mom has autism
and when he was seven he had his first
grand mal seizure at Disneyland he fell
to the ground he stopped breathing
Chinese parents are Korean immigrants
they came to the country with limited
resources speaking little English so it
was up to geni to enroll her family and
Medicaid she was nine years old that
moment defined her mission and that
mission became her company and that
company bid on one and delivered on that
contract
here's Jeanne to tell you why Medicaid
saved my family from bankruptcy and
today it provides for key moms health
and for millions of others noona is my
love letter to Medicaid every row of
data is a life whose story deserves to
be told with dignity and Jeannie's story
tells us that a compelling sense of y
can be the launch pad for our objectives
remember that's what we want to have
accomplished and objectives are
significant they're action-oriented
they are inspiring and they're a kind of
vaccine against fuzzy thinking you'd
think a rock star would be an unlikely
user of objectives and key results but
for years Bono has used okay ours to
wage a global war against poverty and
disease and his one organization has
focused on two really gorgeous audacious
objectives the first is debt relief for
the poorest countries in the world the
next is universal access to anti-hiv
drugs now why are these good objectives
let's go back to our checklist
significant Czech concrete yes
action-oriented yes inspirational well
let's just listen to Bono
so you're passionate how passionate what
actions does your passion need you to do
if the heart doesn't find a perfect
rhyme with the head and your passion
means nothing the okay or framework
called
the madness the chemistry contained
inside it it gives us an environment for
risk for trust or failing is not a
fireable offense and when you have that
sort of structure in environment and the
right people
magic is around the corner I'd love that
okay ours cultivate the madness in magic
is right around the corner this is
perfect
so with Genie we've covered the wise
with Bono the what of goal-setting let's
turn our attention to the house remember
the house are the key results that's how
we meet our objectives and good results
are specific and time-bound they're
aggressive but realistic they're
measurable and they're verifiable those
are good key results in 1999 I
introduced okay ours to Google's
co-founders Larry and Sergey here they
are twenty four years old in their
garage and Sergey enthusiastically said
he'd adopt them well not quite
what he really said was we don't have
any other way to manage this company so
we'll give it a go and I took that as a
kind of endorsement but every quarter
since then every Googler has written
down her objectives and her key results
they've graded them and they've
published them for everyone to see and
these are not used for bonuses or for
promotions they're set-aside they're
used for a higher purpose and that's to
get collective commitment to truly
stretch goals in 2008 a Googler
sundar pichai took on an objective which
was to build the next generation client
platform for the future of web
applications in other words build the
best browser he was very thoughtful
about how he chose his key results how
do you measure the best browser it could
be heed clicks or engagement or retinol
he said numbers of users because users
are going to decide if chrome is a great
browser or not so he had this one three
year long object
build the best browser and then every
year he stuck to the same key results
numbers of users but he upped the ante
in the first year
his goal was 20 million users and he
missed it got less than 10 second year
he raised the bar 250 million he got the
37 million users somewhat better in the
third year he upped the ante once more
to a hundred million he launched an
aggressive marketing campaign broader
distribution improved the technology and
kaboom he got a hundred and eleven
million users here's why I like this
story not so much for the happy ending
but it shows someone carefully choosing
the right objective and then sticking to
it year after year after year it's a
perfect story for a nerd like me now I
think of okay ours is transparent
vessels that are made from the Watson
house of our ambitions what really
matters is the why that we pour into
those vessels that's why we do our work
okay ours are not a silver bullet
they're not going to be a substitute for
a strong culture or for stronger
leadership but when those fundamentals
are in place they can take you to the
mountaintop I want you to think about
your life for a moment do you have the
right metrics take time to write down
your values your objectives and your key
results do it today if you'd like some
feedback on them you can send them to me
I'm John at what matters.com if we think
of the world changing goals of an Intel
of a noona of Bono of Google they're
remarkable ubiquitous computing
affordable healthcare high quality for
everyone ending global poverty access to
all the world's information here's the
deal every one of those goals is powered
today by ok ours now I've been called
the Johnny Appleseed of ok ours for
spreading the good gospel according to
Andy Grove but I want you to join me in
this movement let's fight for what it is
that really matters because we can take
okay ours beyond our businesses we can
take them to our families to our schools
even to our governments we can hold
those governments accountable we can
transform those informations we can get
back on the right track
if we can and do measure what really
matters thank you
[Applause]
[Music]